nintendo kicked off the morning of
tuesday at e3 with a press conference
full of some familiar faces and some
surprises and now we've got Nintendo
game right here on stage Super Mario
maker joining me Ali rap from Nintendo
treehouse alley welcome to the stage
Nintendo time I this is one of many
Nintendo games you're gonna be bringing
by this time around because you guys
have a big lineup super BFFs it's gonna
be exciting well you're gonna meet some
of my friends too we have a lineup of
iconic hosts that are purple love to see
year after your autograph yeah uh but
we're kicking it off with Super Mario
maker people getting to make their own
Mario's stages yes wash maker on
wherever you want for a fan art yeah
it's like kind of a letterhead or areas
yeah like a big kind of more and more
thing especially with Wii U yeah
splatoon fan art is basically my
favorite thing to look at on the
internet now it's magical universe are
it yes yeah it's a super cool yeah but
in Mario maker you're creating a level
art playable art if you will is a game
designer and so we're gonna take a look
at some stages here yeah we are so what
we're seeing is actually the course
world which is the online portion of or
one of the online portions of Super
Mario maker ok and so with course world
what you can do is you can sort through
all the stages that people from around
the world have created so say for
example that you want to play a really
really hard stage you can sort by
difficulty like i'm talking like lost
levels plus you want it to get real
nasty real nasty yeah does it do people
make real mean stages they do yeah some
of those people are in treehouse are you
one of these people right we not okay
really bad at making Satan but um yeah
some of them get really tough and so you
can sort by difficulty you can sort by
I'm all kinds of things like you can
follow friends uh-huh um so that you can
kind of keep updated with when they're
making stages so you can play their
stages can you follow somewhat like say
you haven't download Kristen
stage and like damn this kristin is good
like yeah you follow that person yeah so
like if you play a stage that you like
you can say oh I really want to follow
this creator even even if you don't know
who it is no you just let you like
they're saved you want to see what else
they do or I see that a lot of people
are following this creator maybe I could
check that out right yeah yep um so you
can sort by like you know popularity
types of category like I said difficulty
I'm all kinds of stuff so that's how you
can find courses that are made better
for you I need kind of the easier stage
I'm not a very good platformer yeah
what's right to some what's kind of a
stage that appeals to you is it a
certain strange design is it an
aesthetic is it one where you jump
around as seldom darlink rather being
able to jump as high as you can don't
look at me like that I mean I deserve it
yeah I absolutely deserve it it was a
slip of the tongue so sorry forgiving
you um as link ever jumped so high in
his little life doesn't like ever jumped
yeah I mean yeah Audrey time off letters
yeah he falls gracefully um my kind of
stage is the folks who can get kind of
like what I like to think of is like the
nintendo design way where it everything
is intuitive uh-huh um there's challenge
there so it makes you feel like I'm
smart even though the game is kind of
walking you through these challenges but
that right mix of you know I'm doing
something but I'm not crying while I'm
doing it right you're not trying don't
have to do it 50 times yeah do it and
there are gonna be sages because you
know they're gonna be sub created from
it everyone you know our whole life so
they're gonna be stages that are gonna
make you want to cry yeah this one is
looking pretty tricky yes practice it
quite a bit so she's rocking it but you
so you notice that you're playing as a
link character right now and so the way
that you do that is there something
called the mystery mushroom and the
mystery mushroom is this item that you
can put into question blocks and
basically you can put it wherever you
can put a regular mushroom right okay
and a mystery mushroom is this thing
where when you pick it up you basically
we're like a costume so you're like
costume Mario so you can be linked you
can be wii fit trainer I mean Isabelle I
love wii fit trainer keeps showing up oh
right we fit trainer is a new member the
stable that happened either right like
it just maybe came into meebo cuz there
was smash yo then people were like I'm
really digging like the weirdest that
wii fit trainer it i'm just gonna spiral
from the horse's trainer next to a
blooper sure that fits that's good so
you can be waived a traitor um and so
how that works is we're not gonna go
into too much of the secret sauce okay
quite yet because it comes out in
September so there's a little bit of
time um but needless to say if you have
a meebo that's gonna kind of expand ah
via meebo possibilities yes now if you
don't have all your amiibo ever you're
so good as anybody make sure those
things are those things are hard to get
get a handle on sometimes I feel like I
know a few people who have multiple
copies of some so they're hoarding it
amiibo hoarder tell you because then
they're everyone's gonna sway refer to
it as their retirement plan sometimes
jokingly yet but the amoeba you know
you're gonna get some bonus stuff as you
guys do but it's not gonna lock the
magic mushroom away by incorrect yeah
you're gonna be able to have fun with
that you're still gonna be able to play
some cool mario costume care hell is
going on here isn't this is one of my
favorites so the one that's just like a
magic koopa slumber party yeah yeah you
get that's a good name for a level you
can't use that alec sleeping yeah it's
like fanfiction so this stage has
basically an infinite number of you know
the fire flowers uh-huh um but it has
also seemingly an infinite number of
enemies so you have to keep going back
not being hit yeah you got a running
back to the bonfire flower go kill
enemies make a little bit of progress
back to the bonfire party yeah this is
the dark souls level Mario right so you
know we're showing that there's all
kinds of different things you can do you
can
create short stages you can create big
stages you can create stages with lots
of enemies you can create stages with no
enemies but really heart jumps uh-huh um
yeah I mean it's just all about like
what kind of Mario says you want to make
and sometimes like I'm like I said I'm
really not good I'm making it's very
modest of you to say yeah real bad okay
I stood up to go full self deprecation
no bad um but so that actually is why I
really am excited about the online stuff
because at first I was like oh cool I
can create Mario stages oh that sounds I
guess I'll make some pipe there's gotta
be a leg I think maybe I can put
something in there I don't know um and
so this ability to like see what other
people are making to sort by maybe I'm
really feeling a masochistic and I'll
try really hard stage 1 Jayda shot load
it up all right right or maybe I'm
really feeling just like I just want to
take it easy i just want to play some
fun easy levels uh-huh i'm just being
able to see the creativity of other
people is for me you're going to be
what's most exciting absolutely and
creativity also now when you went a
creator sort of makes their stage do
they pick anesthetic because they you've
got super mario brothers super mario
three super mario world yep new super
mario brothers you yep and we're seeing
it or we will soon um on gameplay so
we're seeing the creation option look at
that little Mario fly through the realm
if only life was that easy way you can
do is you can change the type of course
tight yeah go from you know like you
said supermarine brother sister murmurs
three etc and you can also change the
course theme and what the cream is is
like you got the ground level you've got
like a ghost house you got underwater
you've got a castle and you lob a world
ice world right right yeah and so you
can only pick one course type per stage
so you can't have like mixing
generations but you can mix theme so you
are not underwater go into a pipe or a
door and then end up like in a ground
yes part of the state okay um so you can
mix themes nice all rights or just this
is a little stylus demo
very well manicured yeah I model ah miss
oh you gotta make a Goomba kimchi I
didn't even know she can hear me I like
when they float floating Cup lessly
likeness yet I'm out of my element I
don't really yeah i mean i'll give it a
shot you guys oh really could you yeah
maybe a gig on land would be better oh
and she also i'm sarah our game player
she is shaking the koopa troopas way
she's doing this right now she's doing
this right now yeah this is live
gameplay it's not whose hand is that you
get to pick the hand that you use you
guys have such as downloadable hands
sometimes you might notice that there's
like a cat paw yes my favorite part nice
um but so you can shake certain things
like for example some enemies some of
the like items and they'll change so the
koopa troopa becomes a red koopa troopa
which if you're familiar with kind of
this very deep canada mario enemies
absolutely surface are a little bit more
aggressive they don't like fall off of
ledges follow you yeah um and you can
also shake items so if we look at the
palette when she pulls it up um there we
go so we see two lines right now you
have those five filled in the full game
in the final in the final game um the
sixth one the six bar is your custom bar
so you can like if you want a bar of all
green you can have a bar above all
greens you can pull it up I'm on green
man customize your palate yeah yeah and
go for the aesthetic you want obviously
making funny shapes and uh Oh are we
playing funny shapes well there's a lot
of funny shapes in the world alley
before what sort of funny [ __ ] but funny
shapes but you guys can allow but levels
in Super Mario maker within reason how
general of a but does it yeah who's on
but watch for Mario man yeah but why
Nintendo's got this all figured out a
magician's fantastic yeah well that's
super mario maker yeah September
September fantastic for the Libyan
London Ali wrap thank you so much for
coming by showing us off looking forward
to more Nintendo awesomeness as e3
continues
yeah all right ladies and gentlemen
coming up next we're going to take like
total 180 from mario maker Nintendo
Danny O'Dwyer's going to come on take
off kick off his segment with hitman
it's going to be good stay tuned